hello everyone this is a game I'm about
to show you has quite a theme to it and
it's not very often that you will see a
game like this played by someone who
become a future world champion it was
played in Moscow in 1915 and the player
with the white pieces is Alexander
Alekhine but but the player with the
black pieces is unknown some stories do
say that the player with the black
pieces is actually young Samuel
Reshevsky but we'll get back to that
after I show you the game so L can play
is efore we have e 6 d4 d5 the French
defense Knight to c3 we have a knight to
f6 Bishop to g5 this is the classical
variation we have Bishop to b4 b5 this
kind of seems like it's winning the
piece but it's really not so we have h6
by by the unknown player we have
ecaptions on f6 h captures on g5 and F
captors in g7 so the rook has to move
rook the g8 and in this position
elephant plays h4 so if black captures
the pawn on g7 elephant will capture the
Jeep on with his h1 and we'll have an
open file for his rook
so black captures G captures on h4 so
Ella kind plays week to g4 protecting
that g7 pawn so we have Bishop back to
e7 to protect the h4 pawn and elegant
plays g3 he really wants to either gets
this h-file for his rook or to capture
an h4 would is pawn so black plays c5
and this is an okay position for white
and for black elephant plays G captors
and h4 and black player captures on d4
and is attacking the knight and in this
position Helicon gets a very interesting
idea and he pushes h5 the the engine
doesn't really approve of this move but
for a human it's very hard to resist a
move like this so we have d captors on C
3 we have h6 we have C captures and b2
attacking the rook so Brooke to be 1 and
now Queen to a5 would check so elegant
plays came to e2 and now we have Queen
captures and a2
so elegant pushes forward to h7 and we
have Queen Castro 0 can be won and now
Ella can plays pawn captures ng8 and
promotes Oh Queen which check so we have
a king to d7 and now between captures
and f7 so we have Queen captures and c2
with check we have King to f3 and now
black can promote yet because this Queen
will capture here on e6 and this Bishop
will fall
so before promotion black plays Knight
to c6 just to protect the bishop so
elegant plays Queen captures on e6 we
have a king - king to c7 and now Ella
can place a me to f4 check we have came
to b6 and now Ella can place a queen to
e3 check and we have a Bishop to c5 just
protecting the king and in this position
alkyne brings another queen into the
game so Ella kind already has three
Queens so we have a be one black also
promotes his pawn to Queen so now we
have five Queens on the board and this
is a well you can imagine how difficult
it is to calculate a certain position
with two queens and on an open board but
imagine how hard it would be to
calculate it with five Queens on the
board but Ella can actually plays the
absolute best move in this position and
he plays rook to h6 and you'll see how
this move is excellent and what I mean
by it and if you look at this position
black is actually not that bad here okay
what does have three Queens but black
has much more pieces and in this
position black should have placed
something like Bishop to g4 check simply
getting his a rook into the game and
then exchanging one Queen for example
with Bishop casters and e3 and black
would bless bless would be okay here
just would be playable but here black
got a little bit materialistic and he
plays Queen captures on f1 but now you
see you'll see what Ella kind has in
mind with this row page six move this
actually allows the white to mate in
five so elephant finds it instantly he
plays Queen to
be for check and now you see this Bishop
cannot capture the Queen because its
Bend and also the knight cannot capture
the Queen because it's been from gerak
and h6 so only move is going to be five
I mean not only move but you do have to
bring the Queen to the defense and we
have Queen to d8 again checking the
black King and again this Knight cannot
capture the Queen because it's pinned
from the rock and age 6 so we have King
to a6 and now once again the Queen from
a3 comes into the attack with Queens the
a3 check and again this nice cannot help
with the defense because it's again
pinned by the rook and h6 so this rooks
rotate six move really really the
fantastic move so we have Queen Queen to
a4 defending so elegant captures Queen
captures on a four Queen captures on a4
and Queen captures on a poor with
checkmate so a very somatic and
beautiful game very rarely that you will
see a game with five Queens on the board
played by a future world champion and
like I said some people just say that
the player with the black pieces was
actually a young Samuel Reshevsky but
this doesn't really seem plausible to me
and although reshef it was quite a
prodigy and he I know who is his famous
for playing that simultaneous exhibition
when he was eight years old I believe
but at the time this game was played in
1915 Reshevsky would have been maybe
four or maybe five years old so I don't
think he would be able to play a game
like this against Alexander Alekhine
but then again who knows I'm interested
to see what do you think do you think
that that it's plausible that Samuel
Reshevsky played this game would black
so yeah that's it for this game I do
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here and I
will see you soon